[Music]
but just just a whole different topic
you made me think of it earlier while we
were talking about Paramount did you see
that uh Warner Brothers was talking
about that they just literally gave
Paramount as an example of a company
that they want to buy they're looking to
invest and buy a big company that so
Brothers is considering buying
Paramount good Lord
truth the the rumor I heard last week um
was that again yet Warner Brothers would
be very interested in because one of the
main reasons is Paramount basically is
the other that has the sort of the
biggest studio in California other than
Warner Brothers they have the biggest
Backlot so they basically one way of
doing is they would basically
monopolize Studio space in in
California that also obviously there's
the back catalog of things but the
problem is Warner Brothers can't afford
to buy
Paramount um so the one question was
there was GNA be sort of like a joint
deal with Netflix that Netflix buy
Paramount
plus and have first dibs on a lot of the
rights and then they will pay for that
and basically then Warner Brothers were
looking at buying just the studio of
Paramount and NBC C would absorb a big
chunk of the rest there's also a rumor
that Paramount are getting ready to do
to sell and one of the things they're
getting ready to do is actually buy Alex
curtzman out of secret
hideout and Rebrand secret hideout as
Star Trek
Studios um so that basically they can
bring Star Trek back into the fold
because the problem is secret hideout
owns certain elements of the Star Trek
franchise now they own what they've
produced basically so Paramount could
say say if you cancel contract for
secret hideout tomorrow powermount
couldn't continue to make strange new
worlds because even though they own Star
Trek they don't own elements of strange
New World secret hideout does um under
the deal it's not really own it but it's
like the sort of copyright thing it's a
bit complicated the guy that did explain
it to me H the George
Lucas sorry they pull a George Lucas
yeah yeah so that's the that's the
that's the idea yeah that um Netflix
would basically buy and absorb Paramount
plus and they would um basically do a
deal with Warner Brothers so Netflix
would basically take over Max and take
over Paramount plus and it would become
one it would all come under Netflix
because H Max is doing quite badly uh on
the streaming platform in America you
have to explain explains to me there's a
streaming platform and then is there is
it like a network thing as well because
there's like well HBO's still their
cable network they still have HBO on
like cable network stuff but Max is no
longer HBO Max but it's it's still what
it was so streaming would shift to
Netflix Power Plus would shift to
Netflix and um but Warner Brothers would
take over the studio so Warner Brothers
would continue to produce material for
Netflix but Netflix would own the thing
and that's apparently the only way
Warner Brothers can Finance it and
that's what they're looking at at the
moment but this isn't going to happen
anytime soon because it's going to be a
massively complicated deal and Warner
Brothers are going to have to massively
refinance to do it because they owe 50
60 billion dollars already oh do you
think that'll like because if they're
that's almost a a hub of different apps
like we were talking about with Amazon
earlier does that kind of coers Amazon
into trying to toss an offer at
Paramount would that maybe make apple
say hey maybe we want to toss an offer
instead of their Disney talks maybe I
don't know if apple and Paramount teamed
up that'd be kind of Glorious in my
opinion but yeah I mean i' I'd love to
see something like that but we're gonna
have to have it I I think Apple will
always survive because financially they
can they could lose money in trillions
no um I mean they got hundreds of
billions in check I mean yeah they're
fine but they can always sort of be that
quality quantity they're almost like a
specialist yeah yeah screaming service
the rest of them aren't so I I do think
I was talking to a business analyst
about this um oh God last year now and
he was saying that that that that there
is going to be a correction there's too
many of these apps now and all these
little companies are doing streaming
like Lion gate over in the UK have got
their own streaming app and they're like
they're taking the piss it's just it's
just getting silly they can't all have
their own streaming app it's got It's
going to there will be a collapse um and
he he actually said the first major one
to go will be Paramount plus it's not
worked it's it hasn't worked since
Coston absolute
Fortune um Paramount I mean they banked
a lot on Mission Impossible this year
Mission Impossible didn't make what it
wanted to do and they they have a few
different things that are just the
things that they were banking on didn't
bank so it's not looking good Mission
Impossible is another one of those
things I just got off the uh in bu with
my library I didn't go to the movies to
see it's still damn good though it's so
good it was I thought it was holy
this is good now I'm just so forked up
over to see part two well they just
changed it it's no longer part two
thankfully that's they changed it to
it's no longer part two so now the next
one's just gonna be Mission Impossible
eight I think yeah which is SM apologize
about his name no they
haven't so they have not bought Curts
out of his contract yet but that is the
conversation that's happening um he is
going to do magnificent 7 MGM though but
Alex curtzman is doing that is Alex
kursman not secret hideout so secret
hideout and not producing so um but Alex
kurtzman has done several projects over
the last even the few years the secret
hideouts deal is basically to do Star
Trek and then get first dibs on anything
secret hideout does but Alex kurtzman
could still work as a producer on other
projects so it's not happened yet but I
would put I wouldn't give you good odds
on that it'll happen in the next six
months he just said happen on Friday in
a followup I don't know if that's just
like super recent or
not you want sir he I don't want to say
his name but he just said happened on
Friday I don't know if that just
like I missed it if it did so I mean
that is excellent if that happened
Friday I'll I'll I'll look into it but
um I I knew I know I knew it was planned
but if it's happened great but I know
he's doing Magnificent Seven but that's
sear secret hideout since when is that a
thing that that just peaked my interest
as you started saying that when when do
we get that is that being made yeah yeah
apparently yeah MGM y so but he's got if
you look at his IMDb he's got several
projects at nothing to do secret hideout
on the go that he's producing so for
other other providers um when they do
Star Trek 4 which I think will happen at
some point that will be Alex kurtzman
with secret that will be secret hideout
producing it um I I think curtzman has
been moving away from secret hideout for
a while to be honest he's um and
Paramount considered a lot of the toxic
toxicity with Star Trek in the last 12
months the last sorry the last few years
is aimed at Alex kursman even with peard
doing well people still about Alex
gsman so um Neil kurtzman you know it's
like what he did with Discovery season
1 has left a bad taste in people's
mouths you know it's like it's it was
not good it was a bad way it was a bad
step it was a very bad First Step yeah
and getting him out of it and um and
like I say I this idea of re rebranding
as Star Trek Studios sort of what
they've it's almost like Lucas within
Disney and sort of things that it'll be
within the thing but separate slightly
and um I I actually think that was a
really really good idea if they do that
I like it because that that allows them
if they do want to leave that company at
any point or if another company wants to
buy out Star Trek particularly if
they're just not working within those
confines whatever they end up doing that
can be done at that point they can go in
there and grab Star Trek without having
all those strangle holds from different
places yeah yeah that's just I think
healthy for an IP yeah exactly and
simplifying all the the contracts have
got so confusing with Star Trek over the
last few years when CBS and Paramount
separated and then CBS owned the movie
rights sorry Paramount owned the movie
rights but CBS owned the TV rights and
then that got convoluted when they then
reabsorbed because all these contracts
still sort of stood and it complicated
so it's it's become really complicated
then they allowed secret Hout to take on
certain elements of the IP and it's just
just so absorbing it in is the cheap but
the end of the day what par out are
thinking is even if it costs them x
amount of Millions to buy Paramount to
buy out secret
hideout it absorbs secret hideout into
Paramount and start Trek will be more
valuable because of it at the
moment it's it's it's probably their
most valuable IP and they don't own all
of it and that's a problem if you're
then going to try and sell the
studio so if this happens if you see
secret hideout or if it did happen
Friday and I just missed it sorry um if
this does happen the next few months
expect power amount to be sold before
the
summer because that's I'm told that's
when they have to restructure load of
their
debt and that's a problem for them
because it's going to cost a
fortune so they've got about 10 billion
worth of debt that they have to
restructure but they took that debt out
when um they were getting interest rates
of like 1% and now all of a sudden it's
5% and 5% of 10 billion
dollar
is a lot $100 million or something
interest alone or something it's going
to be a problem so I I think they're
they're looking to sell because of
[Music]
that